rossi your story well we got a fun story
all the way from australia the good news
network reports when carl stanovich's
neighbor texted him quote would you be
able to take my bins out please with a
heart emoji uh carl went to town for
real he grabbed knicks bins and had a
five-hour adventure
complete with pictures he took the bin
to the beach the surf club a local bar
for a coldie which they say there's a
beer in australia and he showed that
trash can a real good time
do you know how much i love this
neighbor that he would do this i mean
that is commitment it's commitment but
there is nothing better than having a
great neighbor i live in palm springs on
one side they bring me tomatoes and
lemons on the other side she bakes me
cookies and brings them i know oh my god
you have the best neighbors in the world
i do but we're here in new york city
wellington says don't talk to the
neighbors like i when we moved it i was
like hi and they were like
um my neighbor rats me out on everything
for real oh for real um anywho um and
you know who you are
oh
i do love the cuteness of the spirit of
this guy taking this trash can and like
just doing something fun for his friend
it's it's just there's it's so sweet yes
and next time you wanted to take the
bins out just be more specific just
bring them out to the street for me
thank you so much love it all right well
before we go we've got the at-home
workout trend that has the goldie hawn
seal of approval that's right she's been
rocking this for ages vogue reports that
people are bouncing into shape with mini
trampolines the workout is called
rebounding and goldie has truly shown us
how it's done wow look at her well do
you expect anything less from goldie
hawn no the best um it works all the
muscle groups at once and it's super low
impact on your joints and all it takes
is one good mini trampoline and a rock
solid bra
you know what's so funny it's like
everything comes full circle this was
the 1980s workout oh yeah what's next
step aerobics
wait by the way i did see that trending
the other day oh my god okay here we are
back to the trampoline here we are and
if it's good enough for goldie hawn
shouldn't we try it too right
i mean
yeah kick off the heels
okay
i don't know that i've ever trampolined
anything in my life this is this could
go terribly wrong everybody so
okay
oh yes yes
oh oh
i'm a natural look
oh you know what i kind of like that
[Applause]
like
oh
i like it too
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you